foreign
are you lost can I help you
okay you want to go up these stairs and
it's kind of the big Temple at the top
you really can't miss it don't jump off
of it though
never mind it's please enjoy Kyoto hi
are you trying to catch a bus can I help
you
okay to the station let's see
yeah it looks like one will leave at 12
15. yeah if you just wait here you'll be
fine yeah no you have changed right okay
my pleasure enjoy Kyoto I hate to
disturb you just uh so you know it's
actually two claps not three just in
case you go to any other temples in
Japan yeah my pleasure enjoy Japan
yeah thank you hi
sit
yeah go ahead yep thank you hi
um I hate to disturb you guys um
I just wanted to let you know that you
really shouldn't be leaning up against
the trees yeah it kind of just causes
the leaves to fall unnaturally early and
kind of like messes up the Wabi saw uh
kind of like Zen aesthetic yeah so if
you could yeah just maybe step away just
a little bit that okay that's perfect
sorry so much please enjoy Japan thank
you
sorry I hate to say this but do you guys
mind being just a little bit quieter
yeah it's just that Japan just recently
reopened and the locals are kind of
re-acclimating to the big influx of
tourists hasn't been this loud here for
like two or three years so yeah yeah
normally yeah thank you so much really
appreciate it enjoy the rest of your
time in Kyoto
Disco
you recognize this
is
sorry just trying to get through here
sorry yep